in the city Where it All Began there's a
creeping sense more suffering is coming
Wuhan kovid's original epicenter is
experiencing a second surge
at hospitals around the city ambulances
cued and so did the sick people arriving
at fever clinics for medicines for
advice and for care it's likely more
people have covered here now than at any
other time before
Mr Lee has brought his wife to the
clinic who has a high fever he knew
people who died in 2020 he thinks he
hopes this time will be easier
foreign
deaths are so narrowly defined here no
one with an underlying condition is
counted officially there's been just a
handful
and it's clearly sensitive officials
extremely anxious it was hard to film
anything without being stopped
and two cars filled with uniformed Men
followed us everywhere we went
and there are other signs too Mr Wang's
small Shop sells traditional funeral
decorations he was one of the few who
agreed to talk and he says he's busy
um
[Music]
thank you
foreign
but the full extent may never be known
the instinct is to conceal it's evident
here at the wet Market where many
believe the very first infections
happened but experts say hundreds of
thousands could be dead by the spring a
million in total
if you didn't know the wet Market was
here you might not even realize there's
almost something Eerie about the way
they've put up these big barricades
covid-19 has brought so much pain and
suffering around the world but for the
city for the country Where it All Began
it feels that that suffering might not
yet be over
there is a desire here to just get on
with life zero covered saved lives but
it was painful and prolonged the worst
of this wave is yet still to come some
say China had time to prepare and didn't
Helena Smith Sky News in Wuhan